cuéntanos realmente se puede obligar a
más a cumplir su promesa de compra y de
no hacerlo cuáles serían las
consecuencias
bueno sí es cierto digamos es de lo que
lo que hizo este acuerdo se firma por 44
mil millones de dólares pero a su vez
hay un digamos este un contrato que
tiene que cumplir tanto la compañía
twitter como el lo más que sería un
contrato de rescisión de cualquiera de
los dos hacia mil millones de dólares
sea cualquiera de las dos que se
retracten de la posición que no tienen
que abonar ese ese monto vamos a eso
sería un poco en la historia y además
este lo que está diciendo twitter es que
ellos brindaron toda la información
correcta para que bueno pueda los más
éste tener la la data que completa para
poder comprar en los más lo que es lo
que dice es que no se le brindó de forma
contundente y habían hablado de un
porcentaje menor y supuestamente según
los estudios que hizo lo más contratando
gente para realizar este el mismo dice
que hay hasta un 20 por ciento de
cuentas
en la compañía con lo cual twitter vale
menos de lo que habían pactado al
principio ahora porque se dice que el
argumento de moscú sobre el número de
cuentas falsas en twitter es sólo una
excusa
porque bueno max es una persona muy
controvertida en todo sentido y la forma
que él se dirigió y cómo se manejó el
drama fue bastante extraña inclusive
como arrancó todo esto él quería comprar
de hecho había comprado un digamos de un
número inferior de acciones después dijo
de avanzar y se lo habían invitado
incluso a estar dentro de la compañía de
la junta directiva él dijo que no y ahí
fue cuando la quiso comprar es una
persona bastante bastante complicada y
no sus acciones son bastante extrañas o
sea es muy es muy conocido por portos de
tipo de movimientos y bueno cuál de las
dos partes se ha visto más perjudicada
en todo este proceso twitter oil o más
acá
creo que twitter por una cuestión muy
lógica porque digamos en las acciones
han bajado por esta esta cuestión
digamos este twitter veníamos trabajando
de una forma bastante también extraña no
se termina de entender bien el negocio
que hay detrás de twitter en los más
siempre avanzó y quiso hacer
modificaciones fue una persona muy pero
muy crítica de la red social y bueno lo
que lo que intentó fue comprarla para
poder cambiar la misma pero yo creo que
tu interés es que el que más esté va a
perjudicada más allá de que seguramente
le va a terminar ganando la la demanda a
los más eso es seguro que yo creo que
desde el primer momento en los más tenía
en la cabeza hacer esto es para también
subir un poco sus éste sus otras
empresas que él tiene él decidió de
varias empresas y por supuesto esto lo
ayuda de alguna manera